i certainly
made a huge mistake uh not only meet him
in the first place but uh i met with him
a number of times he was a
bad person bill gates says he regrets
his friendship with jeffrey epstein i
didn't realize that
in a meeting with him
almost downplayed
the incredibly awful things he did the
billionaire businessman sat down with
the today show on tuesday to discuss his
new book how to prevent the next
pandemic and opened up about his
association with the late financier
according to a 2019 story in the new
york times the 66 year old microsoft
co-founder met with epstein several
times beginning in 2011. i certainly
made a huge mistake i didn't realize
that in a meeting with him
almost downplayed
the incredibly awful things he did
epstein was already a convicted sex
offender when their meetings began in
2008 epstein pled guilty to procuring a
person under 18 for prostitution and
felony solicitation of prostitution and
in a recent interview with cbs mornings
bill's ex-wife melinda seemed to suggest
that his association with epstein put a
strain on their marriage i did not like
that he'd had meetings with jeffrey
epstein now
and you made that clear to him
i made that clear to him i also met
jeffrey epstein exactly one time did you
yes because i wanted to see who this man
was and um
i regretted it from the second i stepped
in the door he was abhorrent
he was
evil personified i had nightmares about
it afterwards so you know my heart
breaks for these young women bill and
melinda announced their divorce last
year after 27 years of marriage forbes
thinks that bill gates is worth 130
billion dollars that would be the
biggest divorce settlement that we are
aware of and gates he says he met with
epstein to raise money i had a goal of
raising money for global health i didn't
realize that in a meeting with him
almost downplayed uh
the incredibly awful things he did you
know i learned more about that over time
but uh you know i'd add that to the list
of big mistakes including you know where
melinda's advice was sound and i i
should have followed it sooner than i
did epstein was found dead in his jail
cell in 2019 with medical examiners
ruling his death a suicide he had been
awaiting trial on federal sex
trafficking charges you never saw
anything where you thought
this doesn't feel right lynda kind of
had a visceral reaction the first time
she met him
no he was a
a bad person
and
you know
i had a reason that i thought those
meetings would lead to something good
but
i shouldn't have done them now gates
says he's in a new chapter of life
healing and moving on from the past well
the divorce is definitely a sad thing uh
you know i
have responsibility
for
causing a lot of pain to my family um
you know it was a tough year
i feel good that uh
all of us are moving forward now you
know my oldest got married uh melinda
and i are you know continuing to work
together so
um
you know it was sad and tragic but uh
you know now we're
we're
moving together
you